[Music]
in two-for-one news submitted by JK
vacation jk jk jk a surrogate mom gave
birth the two babies are discovered one
of them is hers don't know it's very
good is it's when a woman is carrying
someone else's child and her bike she's
just renting out her womb oh let me see
been [ __ ] oh you made a funny it's
given better bing-bam-boom yeah so this
culture
couple of the mother the circuit mother
name is Jessica Jessica
yeah she's 31 years old 31
ha ha ha ha yeah so after having two
successful pregnancies she her and her
husband were thinking like you know we
should get back to struggling couple out
there you know like I'm down sick to
carry someone else's child or they were
saying I hope I only saw Mona because
I'm trying to go to last play I guess
let's do it well they did discuss what
they were gonna do with the money and so
they were planning on buying a house
that was right they get like 60 grand
holy moly this couple received 30,000
okay y'all got low-balled said yes so
thirty thousand for this pregnancy's
we're gonna mount though it's like par
uh for all the work the body goes to
down 30 so she so they ended up being
matched with a chinese couple always and
they paid her for the pregnancy and and
then when she soon as she said that her
and her husband followed like all the
procedures writing everything that they
had to do and so once the doctor come
firm like yes you're pregnant you're
good to go you can have sex with your
husband now but make sure to wear a
condom which they did they ended up
having sex but then later on she
discovered that she was pregnant with
two kids two babies so they thought that
what happened was that that single
embryo split and then it would be
identical twin she's saying that the
doctor that she went to through the
agency never told her that the babies
were in different sexes which is a clear
sign that it's two separate babies my
eternal she's a new doctor well it was
through the agency so then that the
surrogacy agency agency we asked you
that
Shanee than you yeah so as a new agent
yeah so then what happened here was that
she ended up getting pregnant again when
she was pregnant which is called super
vacation vacation super vacation fertile
this couple is already at you right and
into some more scrap poom-poom they got
another one yeah chica pop and they were
condo she's getting come from pre-cum oh
my god got pregnant naturally and then
so anyway so then she ends up giving
birth back in December 2016 and in her
contract it said that she was allowed to
spend one hour with the twins with just
her and the babies just to make sure
like everything's okay for whatever
reason but she was saying that was
[ __ ] up cuz mrs. Liu which is the fake
name that they're giving the Chinese
couple that she just immediately took
the babies home like she didn't even get
to see the kids are they gonna
breastfeed and study both babies because
they thought that like any surprise you
ended up getting two for the price of
one so then they upped her feet to
35,000 so she got an extra $5,000 for
the second kid so it's like I already
paid you for the kid is mine
well see that's the things uh at that
moment when the kids were born she
didn't see the kids then the next day
the mom did like a 10-minute visit to
see how she was doing and she ended up
showing her a photo of the twins and
that's when
nothing alike the second mom was she
ended up mentioning like oh that's
interesting like they look different and
in the mall the mrs. Liu she got all the
potential II just took the device and
she was like she just got a weird about
it right so then a few weeks later the
mrs. Liu sent her a text of the photo of
the twins again and saying like do you
know why like they might look different
like do you can you might see can you
see like why do you look different
how come one has blue eyes and then why
is one albino
what is the ethnicity of that
okay okay what about the cuz it might be
hard to tell if they're both Asian okay
alright okay
for the surrogate is an Asian company
great so one over kid though one of the
twins is a black and white so then later
on is the sperm the daddy sperm yes then
later on they got a DNA test and they
determined that this baby here is not
biologically related to the Asian couple
at all no way Wow age we have the
picture of no very one thing that you
guys should do I'm pretty sure you guys
are fantastic parents but teach your kid
how to smile cuz that's just crazy
that's what a parent adults that don't
know how to smile all I do know what
that is not a parent's fall because I've
tried telling either got ten sometimes
they'll be like wait you said you don't
know how to smile yeah when I was a kid
all of my pictures every single one was
like this I pressed the [ __ ] out of my
lips like a photo smile you know like
you can't control everything your kid
does oh yes my mind that smile was like
a cartoon it was going up like this like
a like a happy face but I pressed my
lips thinking that it went up like this
it's like he's so uncomfortable and look
at this one
oh not Terrell yeah so these are the two
kids that they already had and this is
the surprise baby and so once was right
all right let me show you another
picture of the baby it's so cute so they
named him Malachi but before I get there
oh that's a coin after the DNA says they
found out like okay where they're not
that related then that's when um the
Chinese couple started demanding for the
surrogate mom like the couple to pay
them twenty-two thousand dollars if they
want their kid back because the Chinese
couple were legally the kids parents
yeah so like they were like hey if you
wanted to get your kid back you have to
pass this amount but then the parents
are [ __ ] ransom yeah so then the
surrogate couple they're saying like
well I don't really blame them because
it seems like someone at the agency got
it in their head that the surrogate mom
was gonna sue the Chinese couple for
whatever reason so that's one that
Chinese couple about scared and they
were like okay well then you've gotta
pay this amount it seemed like the
agency from the mom [ __ ] yeah so the
she's not like shady ass Chinese [ __ ]
the surrogate couple is trying to sue
the the agency because they're the ones
that kind of [ __ ] everything up
because they didn't want to take any
responsibility or like they're just like
but then the agency is coming saying
like no we provide everything that we
can we did everything we could we gave
them doctors and all this stuff if you
sue that agency that yeah and so now
this surrogate couple is like in debt
wait did they pay the 22 no so but so
the reason why they're in debt is
because they got a lawyer to help them
with all this debt cuz they were still
trying to get their kids because a
couple the Chinese couple would still
not give them their kid because they
thought that they needed to get money in
order for them to transfer the kid over
it was just like get back at five grand
and shut the [ __ ] up yeah the agency or
it seems like the agency got it in the
Chinese couples head like hey well since
you don't want anything to do with this
kid since this kid's not yours and put
it put the kid up for adoption oh my god
and then they set up adoptive parent
like prospective parents for this babe
I would [ __ ] kill ya at least the
baby came back like me how was it song
borin
Malakai shut the [ __ ] up
why are you speaking to me like that
there would she it was too much I see
the first two months of this baby's life
visit the Chinese couple and like with
them and like they're about to adopt him
and like that's what this couple were
like holy [ __ ] we just bought a house we
don't have money like everything that we
have we've got to put into the lawyer to
try to get it their kid cuz you're like
it's our kid like what about the pay to
get our kid back how the Chinese people
even like not that the Chinese I'm
a-gonna contracts people but why did the
other parents they're like yo putting
him up for adoption even though we know
they're legal parents is a great idea
you know that's why it seems that the
agency [ __ ] up here in many ways ok
yeah cuz they should have stepped for
that yo we got a Miss a diagnosis the
doctor thought they were twins but we
[ __ ] up and they actually aren't so
we'll sort it out like they're the
middleman that's the whole point of
having a baby you want to just wipe
their hands clean and be like just adopt
the kid and or try to get money back I
think the shitty thing about that is as
the other cut no no not the surrogate
parents is that they train this child as
if it's not a person
oh I don't want to deal with this
problem is just send it for adoption you
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's the irritating part
you know what I mean like you know [ __ ]
everything else it's like you're
treating this child like it's a [ __ ]
like a commodity yeah I'm just gonna
toss the [ __ ] kid away you [ __ ]
bastards but luckily everything looks
fine now like Malachi's with his family
the family still in debt so they're
trying to figure out like how to get out
of this but at least they'll have to pay
that twenty two thousand that they were
the management were they cool with the
Chinese family or did they fight with
them because the way that the article
was saying is that they they didn't see
it their fault I'm not sure like there
throughout the whole pregnancy how it
was the surrogate mom does mention
though like it was in her contract that
she was allowed
our after the kids were born in and the
Chinese mother was like no no they just
took the kids so that part is kind of
shady
other than that though like she's the
surrogate mother is just saying like it
seemed like the agency got it in her
head that she needed the money
oh sure I would understand if I was a
parent that was paying for the baby
I don't know afford it the surrogacy or
whatever yeah yeah yeah yeah I would
also kind of be like no I want the kids
to bond with me as soon as possible like
I wouldn't want them to bond with the
stranger as soon as they're born so from
that perspective I would see it because
the first like you know the first time
they come out it's important all that
all right
yeah it's important yeah that Goldeneye
was important that they bond with the
mom so but then I guess if she felt that
we should've taken it out of the
contract oh maybe she didn't see herself
yeah that's what Rex moments cracks I
mean I thought that contract would kind
of protect them in a way because this is
like it was kind of sort of a violation
or even then like it was a pre extra
five thousand for like another kid that
was more of a surprise to them when
they're only expecting one I think the
real thing was she was like you look
like a stupid lady I don't want my kid
to be stupid so get your stupid away
from me
that's what was happy said yeah that's
what it was really going on I don't like
how they just treat that kid like it's I
think what what happens is that because
she didn't go through the labor she
don't understand she don't know how
worth how much work like you know you
put more value over things that you've
paint over and yeah I put a lot of work
into this [ __ ] right so like
imagine if you just a baby gets dropped
off on your front door from a stork
that's true you get two of them you're
like I didn't want the other one it's
like a puppy yeah let's get that other
one over there
in California by the way whoa did the
other one look Chinese yeah the other
one was biologically the the Chinese
couple's son
this baby's kind of all look alike when
they come out don't they do they look
really similar no she mentioned like if
you look different cuz one was darker no
life we saw my we saw my nephew's do you
me really look different they look whate
they look way different well I mean if
you have a Chinese kid and then a half
black half white kid I want one one kids
like [ __ ] like six inches it's like
three feet long right you know what the
[ __ ] but does it make them brothers no
because they don't share any wound
brothers you're not paternal oh like a
Wolverine DNA though it's just the fact
that there was no Santa brothers movie
the [ __ ] Chicanos are honored today
it didn't stink yeah wooden mates what
did you say brace yourself and [ __ ] you
guys again this
[Music]
you
you